hey guys I wanted to before Chris left I
had him sit back down and I wanted to
have our intern Gianni Paolo come in and
Gianni is I mean he's an adult but he
looks like he's not I mean sometime
you'll see you know little kids will run
up just on the street and yell yell
you're it and just touch him and they
run off so obviously he's you know
people see him in other realms children
see him he could trick or treat and it's
no big deal but I wanted to see what
Chris Hansen's thought of Gianni if he
thought he would be good bait for pedia
files out there and so here's an extra
segment of me bringing Gianni back in a
studio and having Chris give him the
once-over hi there
have a seat what are you doing here
what's in the bag Chris I put in we have
our our intern who's also a famous actor
but nobody knows him yet because his
movie isn't out yet but your time will
come
yeah what was that G on Dateline last
like two months ago well good for you
yeah you really yeah okay well look we
want to know Chris if like Jionni's a
young man he plays a high school student
in a new film is this the kind of guy
you would use absolutely oftentimes we
have the on-site decoys join us they're
young acting students who maybe 20 21
years old but who look younger and you
fit the fit the part yeah we could put
you to work
you know the actual decoys who do the
conversations with the prevent with the
Predators are from all walks of life
it's all online but for the two people
that we have in the home during the
investigation it it's somebody like you
and in the female version so what do you
like train them beforehand like what do
you what do you have to tell them like
what are they yeah and do you tell them
that or does it produce or tell me it's
it's all of the above so the security
people will run them through you know
don't get too close
you know if they go in for a hug I'll be
right back and just scoot you know
Hanson will be out in a minute you know
don't engage don't physically get
involved you know never cross the
threshold of the door and again as the
guys coming in and there are often
moments where there's a come here come
here let's go for a ride and there's
this negotiation where you got to think
on you
feet in and we don't want to put too
much pressure
yeah on the onside decoy because it's
not fair because they're not trained
journalist has anything ever happened to
you know we wouldn't lot we would yeah
and what type of attire would you put
Gianni in because I know you know like
is this something you would will let him
wear or what it what did what is a decoy
kind of wear to make them seem most you
know delectable that's pretty close
hoodies are big oh yeah because you know
sometimes there's a disconnect between
the online decoy and the on-site decoy
hmm
so if somebody says you've got blue eyes
and you know red hair and you don't the
hoodie is acceptable to to wear right it
just gives him a moment just a little
extra something like what's going on you
know once they're in and I'm out right
you know the last investigation we had a
guy who the way it was set up is the
kitchen island was right next to a
bathroom and he was on the road for
several hours wanted you to the bathroom
mhm and so that's always risky because
if somebody you know traps themselves in
there then he got a problem right but it
looked like it was gonna go okay so he
goes and does at the decoy leaves and I
walk in so when he goes into the
bathroom he is saying goodbye to a young
woman when he comes out I'm waiting for
him
and imagine this startling Cinderella
yeah a verse do um and is that uh does
the decoy as the decoy ever made a
mistake that you guys like release or
just an accidental mistake no it's it's
it's tightly choreographed I mean and
they're they're only exposed you know
we've had some very gifted decoys over
the years yeah one of whom was at in
theater school at New York and she was
so good that we actually had her travel
with us Wow Casey she was that good and
it got to the point where she developed
skills in a trust level where we would
allow her to engage and she was good at
you know getting stuff going on the
natural environment because once I walk
out they know yeah I mean they may think
for sex it's probably all it's the man
that's the mad dad it's the detective
and alter right and sometimes yes all
your Chris Hanson I said well ha
you know that is why I watch the show
all the time yes Tonto but yeah would
you believe that they've watched the
show yeah they also aren't doing because
it's a disconnect I think from who they
are in that moment to who they are when
they're on the inner right and there's
almost in some cases there's been this
moment of excitement we had one guy down
in Georgia we did a piece with the
Jasper County Sheriff's Department down
there and he's like oh my god I can't
believe I just met Chris Hanson I said
you get why you're meeting Chris yeah
and he slams his head down on the table
I said do you think that there at a
certain point became men who got started
doing predatory stuff just to try and
meet you I'm serious about that people
joke about it on the internet you know
and I don't think so that's a rough way
to yeah you know go to a book signing
yeah watch the shows on the TV you know
don't don't do that that's a rough me
you know nothing good is gonna come out
of it
so honestly on Jionni if you had to get
him out of ten and you don't have to
give him a ten and you shouldn't but
what would you give him on the decoy
scale I think he's you know nine point
five and I know and it's the height he
could he could age out soon though I'll
call it I'll tell you I'm like five
seven in the morning yeah you're an inch
taller in the morning so are you really
yeah you know that no yeah so I'm about
five seven in the morning and well I
think that would work here but I place
like in high school I play 16 on TV and
but like I'm 22 so I'm kind of getting
there yeah so you would it would there
be a chance you actually could even use
him we could we could but we usually
keep the the ages you know 13 and 12 and
13 maybe 14 oh that's the age you're
going for them to look yeah yeah because
then there's no there's no gray area
about you know I mean we for instance
you know we had this guy show up and he
was there for a 13 year old boy and he
says yeah he says well I didn't have my
glasses on I thought it said 18 and I
was yeah what's happened yesterday
cops interviewing Remini says well you
were able to find the address okay
without your glasses you know your
vision was okay then yeah but didn't you
know that guy yeah who's on that he rode
the train yeah the Train guy when I when
I had a house is a real estate agent
yeah exactly
has you ever encountered
I'll never known before like that or no
no that was the only one and I you know
it was funny because I hadn't seen him
in a couple years anyway it wasn't like
a friend right he was just he was on
there was a social car where a lot of
guys did have a couple beers in the way
home and he would always be kind of
lurking about on the periphery and and
nobody ever thought much of it and all
of a sudden he's yeah there and I'm
looking gosh that guy looks familiar and
I walk I just cruise snow crews know
it's not what it looks like in the crew
all things that he just knows rate from
television mm-hmm you know it turns out
there this is a guy yeah yeah did you uh
who's somebody you beat in tennis that
was like a celebrity you played against
you beat at least in one match um well
I've never beaten any celebrities
I have warmed up one of the McEnroe
brothers which which was good but not in
it not our match that's cool
I'll tell you a funny story so mark
McEnroe who is the third brother who
didn't play pro tennis but is incredibly
gifted I was in it like Cooper Manning
he's the third Manning brother
yeah but he's easier to probably get
these incredible tennis players you know
but you know he's a lawyer and he has a
fine life and he's close with Johnny
Patrick but we were in this round robin
and the fella I was playing with younger
very talented I mean the reason why I
ever won anything was I had a 20 you
know one year old you know kid with a
105 mile an hour sure you know so huh
you know yeah you're just the look to
the operation I just don't miss you know
and we were supposed to play mark
McEnroe and this other fella Jim Green
and they both had vacation places in in
Rhode Island and sunken traffic couldn't
get back to Connecticut so they had to
forfeit the match and so it says you
know Hansen mister you know moving on to
the next round and say people who didn't
weren't around that the course at that
time said hey you guys beat Mac and
rollin and green it's like they never
showed up or as a friend of mine says he
said you know I've never lost a doubles
match my partner has presence and thank
you so much pleasure yep Johnny will
keep we'll get your number
yes all right yes that's a dream
especially we shoot something on the
other west coast yeah we'll see you
online
well you're gonna be the one that we're
walking in on no I will not he looks
really yeah can you give us one I'll
have a seat to you just add the general
you ever have a seat
and listen to the podcast thank you so
much
[Music]
little time for me to set that parking
brake myself
[Music]